bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 78 weekend vous le
savez l'émission consacrée à vos loisirs
et vos idées de sorties Michell elmidero
viendra nous rejoindre en plateau pour
nous parler parler des rendez-vous
sportifs F pas manqué ce weekend nous
parlerons bien sûr de cinéma de musique
aussi mais tout de suite place à notre
première invitée elle est venue nous
donner des idées de loisirs pour occuper
vos
vacances Sylvie Laona bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes la directrice d'ivelim
tourisme et en ce début de vacances
scolaires vous êtes venu nous proposer
plusieurs idées de sortie alors on part
tout de suite du côté de Rambouillet à
la Bergerie Nationale pour y découvrir
l'univers du cirque voilà ça s'appelle
La Bergerie fait son cirque et donc on
peut toujours y découvrir les animaux de
façon assez classique mais vous avez des
magiciens le fermier magicien qui vient
vous faire des des jolis tours euh les
enfants
pourront se transformer en animaux et en
plein de choses en réalisant leur
propres masque et puis évidemment les
animaux vont participer à un spectacle
animalier que les enfants pourront
découvrir tout spécialement à l'occasion
des vacances très bien on reste dans
l'univers du cirque avec un stage
théâtral à les staminés de gu en cours
cette fois-ci voilà alors ça s'appelle
chercher son clown et en fait c'est un
un stage de comme vous l'aviez dit de
théâtre de mim de pantomim les enfants
vont apprendre à parler fort à écouter
aussi son voisin à à se chercher un
petit peu à innover avoir un nouveau
personnage et puis tout simplement
prendre confiance en soi puisque c'est
vraiment l'idée l'idée de ce stage de
théâtre euh un stage qui dure cette
fois-ci une semaine he du 16 au 20
février très bien alors pour les jeunes
scientifiques en devenir également il y
en a pour tous les goûts le parc aux
étoiles de Triel sur scène propose
également des des ateliers voilà alors
là c'est encore tout autre chose le parc
aux étoiles qui est un un vraiment un
site qui est tout spécifique au
Département des ivelines euh propose des
des petits stages sur des différentes
choses comme par exemple découvrir le
monde des petites bêtes découvrir les
plan
autour du système solaire ou bien encore
travailler la langue des signes comme
les astronautes par exemple des choses
extrêmement différentes qui vont bien
instruire les enfants allez on part du
côté de Saint-Germain ENL maintenant le
musée Maurice Saint-Denis propose
également des ateliers d'art plastique
et des stages le musée Maurice Denis
Maurice Denis voilà qui est un abis qui
est un peintre qui est connu et donc qui
qui va permettre de proposer tout un tas
de stages pour les enfants euh pour tous
les âges donc il y a des stages de
gravure il y a des stages de peinture
avec du fusin de
l'aquarelle ou aussi des CIS grasses euh
vous avez également des stages avec les
parents et les enfants avec des jeux
autour des Nabis et puis des stages pour
les tout petits hein de 4 à 6 ans qui
sont spécial spécialement réalisé pour
eux euh vraiment tout un tas de de
choses à l'occasion des des vacances qui
qui leur sont proposé et tout
spécifiquement organisé pour eux très
bien au musée de la Fournaise de Chatou
cette fois la compteuse invite les
enfants dans son univers de légende
voilà alors au musée fournaise à Chatou
effectivement il y a une compteuse qui
va raconter tout un tas d'histoires
autour de personnages qui commencent
maintenant à être classique pour ceux
qui connaissent bien le musée fournaise
euh c'est donc Renoir le renard euh
c'est Maurice le canotier et puis aussi
la déesse du fleuve les petites bêtes
des rivières et tout ça ça fait une
histoire qui est assez extraordinaire et
les enfants vont être complètement
captifs autour de la compteuse euh du
côté d'éancour maintenant à France
Miniature une activité pour les plus
gourmands cette fois-ci les mercredis et
les dimanches des vacances voilà alors à
France Miniature on va faire des sablés
enfin on va pas les faire on va les
décorer et c'est Sylvie
Kempler qui est une qui est une chef
connue qui fait des ateliers de cuisine
à à plaisir la cuisine facile.com
d'ailleurs et donc Sylvie Kempler va
proposer aux enfants de décorer des
sablés pour qu'il soit aussi beau que
bon et donc on peut décorer on va faire
travailler son imaginaire et après on se
régale les sablés des deux gourmands une
entreprise ginoise exctement on a déjà
parlé également sur notre chaîne on
reste en cuisine avec un atelier pour le
moins original à Versailles h c'est
let's cook in English alors là on va
apprendre à faire de la cuisine en
parlant anglais donc c'est à la fois
ludique et puis instructif euh donc on
va faire des des cookies on va faire
aussi des pizzas on va faire des euh des
bronies sandwich cookies alors tout un
programme euh et donc se régaler après
avoir un peu appris appris à parler
l'anglaisord et à Notter qu' un atelier
en famille est également proposé le
samedi 21 février voilà alors le musée
de la ville de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
propose lui aussi des ateliers pour les
enfants de 5 à 15 ans oui alors là euh
comme il y a une exposition en ce moment
qui s'appelle mtoi dans le bain les
ateliers vont avoir lieu sur cette
thématique donc on pourra apprendre à
faire des maquettes de salle de bain et
aussi préparer son propre gel douche
donc ça pour les enfants c'est c'est
super mais aussi il y a des des choses
plus classiques qui sont les comptes
autour du patrimoine de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline et et ce genre de d'ateli qui
sont plus plus classiques toutes les
vacances de de l'année n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre sur le le site internet du
musée de la ville on termine et on
revient à Rambouillet au Domaine
national et des activités adaptées en
fonction des âges voilà au Château de
Rambouillet donc on peut avoir des des
des activités pour les grands
c'est-à-dire que ce sera une chasse au
trésor cette chasse au trésor permettra
de trouver le trésor qui a été ramené
par Napoléon en 1ier qui est le fameux
trésor égyptien et puis après pour les
tout petits on va préparer le château
pourquoi parce qu'on attend le roi et la
comptesse de Toulouse va accompagner les
enfants pour préparer le château le
faire beau pour que le roi puisse le
découvrir sous son meilleur aspect voilà
tous les ateliers qu'on qu'on propose
pendant pendant ces vacances et noté que
celui-là se passe tous les jours sauf le
mardi jour de de fermeture du musée
voilà vous les avez pas toutes cité donc
mais bien sûr d'autres activités sont à
découvrir pour les vacans sur le site
internet sorti Riveline c'est ça merci à
vous d'êtreevenu sur notre plateau merci
on passe maintenant à l'agenda des
spectacles du
weekend
comme chaque hiver la ville des Mureaux
se met à l'heure du cirque le 14e
Festival International du Cirque prend
ses quartier au parc du Sautour le 14 et
le 15 février l'occasion d'y découvrir
des numéros exceptionnels voici un petit
aperçu en
photo
et à la médiathèque des se Marel en
cours 1 heure de compte à venir écouter
en famille un bibliothécaire vous
plongera dans l'univers onirrique de
l'artiste Alexandra fontaine l'artiste
viendra également à la rencontre des
enfants pour leur expliquer les œuvres
exposé rendez-vous ce samedi à 10h30
l'entrée est
libre
la boutique d'maus sattrape change de
locaux et s'agrandit il se trouve
désormais à pôul emploi enfin face à
pôul emploi nousous sommes rendus dans
leur
locaux vous allez réglé après vous
revenez me voir je vais vous faire un
grand paquet avec la valise je vais vous
la garder les bénévoles d'maus et les
clients ont déjà pris leur marque dans
la nouvelle boutique ouverte dans la ZAC
du Buisson de la coudre des locaux qui
remplacent ce situés dans le centreville
de Trapp qui ont été préemptés dans le
cadre de l'aménagement du plateau urbain
de la National 10 nous avons choisi un
local
commercial c'est-à-dire moderne avec
beaucoup d'espace adapté à la clientèle
à l'accès et pour l'instant nous en
sommes ravis la surface de vente est
d'orinavant de 1000 m Carr trois
boutiques en rez-de-chaussée pour les
vêtements le bric à brac et les livres
un espace est réservé aux meubles et au
produits d'électroménagers le magasin a
ouvert ce samedi en une journée près de
4 personnes sont venu voir les nouveaux
locaux beaucoup plus grand que l'aut
qu'il avait avant l' il se trouvait dans
le centreville là-bas et tout était
beaucoup serré là c'est c'est beaucoup
mieux quand même je viens souvent parce
que je cherche des anciens fauteuil pour
les rétaper c'est plus Faé et puis on a
plus le choix beaucoup de gens nous
amènent leurs carton leurs vêtements
beaucoup beaucoup de dons tous les jours
nous sommes ouvert tous les jours pour
les dons comme Christian la communauté
de Trapp compte une petite trentaine de
bénévle pour s'occuper du magasin en
dehors de ces bénévoles la communauté
accueillit auparavant des compagnons ils
ont été jusqu'à 17 l'année dernière mais
aujourd'hui les pavillons qui les
accueillaient vont être rasés et faute
de locaux pour les recevoir ils ne sont
plus que deux aujourd'hui la communauté
a été un petit peu éparpillé à partir du
mois de juin pour essayer de les recaser
un petit peu partout dont certains avec
des droits à la retraite et puis
d'autres qui sont repartis dans d'autres
communautés la communauté Emmaus négocie
actuellement avec la mairie de trappe
pour retrouver une solution
d'hébergement des compagnons dans des
foyers
sociaux et on passe tout de suite à
l'actualité Sport du
weekend notre journaliste sportif Michel
elmidoro nous a rejoint en plateau avec
son invité bonjour bonjour yolen alors
quels sont les rendez-vous à ne pas
rater ce weekend alors il y aura très
peu matchs ce weekend avec donc les
vacances scolaires euh je sais que donc
vous êtes un peu déçu hein yolen vous
êtes une amatrice de sport
alors il il y aura tout de même du
football avec manilamo qui affronte donc
ce weekend bayinoisi pour le compte donc
du championnat donc de 2e division alors
est-ce que vous êtes confiant sur ce
match très confiant oui oui bien sûr on
a un match de retard donc on est premier
avec trois points d'avance et si on
gagne ce match on aurait on vair on va
avoir se points d'avance donc on est
très confiant oui alors comment
expliquez-vous justement cette première
place Cyril arvinberro bah c'est une
équipe l'équipe d'amis on se connaît
depuis maintenant 8 10 ans et à chaque
fois qu'on rentre sur le terrain déjà on
rendage à notre ami Franck qui est parti
très tôt
euh donc voilà et dernière c'est ça
c'était non Franck ça fait maintenant
plus de 3 ans qu'il est parti et donc à
chaque fois qu'on rentre sur le terrain
on pense à lui donc on a la Arne et et
voilà et est-ce que vous sentez que
cette saison vous vous pouvez monter
vous êtes actuellement premier est-ce
que vous sentez que vous pouvez monter
bah si on gagne dimanche 7 point
d'avance là c'est bien parti
donc il y a un match contre le chînet le
3è et les clés donc clé sous bois si on
gagne ces deux matchs là c'est la montée
et ENF c'est bon quoi donc vous avez
tris points d'avance là pour l'instant
vous pouvez en avoir se se avec ce match
en retard si vous le remportez ce
dimanche c'est ça exactement et est-ce
qu'il y a pas trop de pression quand
vous êtes les premiers est-ce que vous
êtes plus attendu sur les rencontres
finalement si bien sûr oui un exemple la
semaine dernière jou Josas Jouan Josas
était là 2h avant donc le match nous on
est arrivé 1h 1h30 maximum en avance et
eux ils étaient là 2h on ils étaient
déjà sur le terrain en train de
s'échauffer
euh oui on voit la différence et est-ce
que le groupe s'entend bien est-ce qu'il
y a une bonne cohision d'équipou oui oui
bien sûr c'est c'est une équipe d'amis
on se connaît depuis depuis tout tout
petit on a commencé en débutant ensemble
oui oui un mauvaistiè on a très très
bonne ambiance en plus il y a il y a un
Mauritanien aussi dans
l'équipe il est nouveau donc il s'est
bien intégré avec nous non très très
bien et alors ce weekend vous avez un
match important donc contre bayinoisi
c'est un match qu'il faut impérativement
remporter impérativement oui même pour
la confiance pour justement prendre les
qu points avoir 7 points d'avance sur le
deuxème donc c'est un match très
important ou et cet adversaire vous le
connaissez binoisi vous connaissez les
forces les faiblesses de l'équipe oui
oui il y a C une équipe il y a 2 ans 3
ans je me suis pris h matchs de de
suspension avec cette équipe donc oui je
connais très bien je suis pris H8 matchs
parce que on a eu c'est un club où il y
a eu pas mal d'attraacation mais
maintenant ça s'estarrangé c'est bonne
ambiance et c'est un derby vraiment ce
ce match non non derby c'est ça les
chevreuses et voisins un petit peu moins
mais valet 78 c'est un derby d'ailleurs
on espère les rencontrer en quart de
finale de Coupe des ivlines donc parce
qu'ils sont qualifiés il y a 2 semaines
donc on espère les rencontrer pour un
beau match un bon match et du coup
bayinoisi c'est c'est un c'est un court
déplacement aussi euh là c'est l'équipe
2 c'est l'équipe 2 qui joue dimanche
l'équipe une ne joue pas donc ils ont le
droit à prendre trois joueurs de la une
donc pard ils vont prendre trois joueurs
de la une donc ça va pas être si simple
que ça malgré qu'ils sont qu'ils soi
avantdernier ça va pas être si simple
que ça et vous allez pouvoir compter
aussi sur votre buteur
aussi là il a plus de 20 buts là là
cette année il explose C on a des
nouveaux joueurs qui donnent des des
meilleurs ballons mais euh non on a une
très belle équipe d'ailleurs Thomas
Bitou a fait pas mal de de de bons match
aussi on a une équipe très forte cette
année
et merci cyil arvinberro d'être passer
sur ce plateau merci à vous merci à vous
on passe à l'agenda Michel oui on passe
à l'agenda alors donc pas pas de gros
rendez-vous sportif ce weekend mais il y
en a quand même quelques-uns on a en
parlé pendant l'interview manilamo se
déplace ce weekend sur le terrain de
oisi pour le compte de la 12e journée du
championnat une victoire permettrait à
manilamo de prendre le large en tête du
classement la rencontre est programmée
au stade de sibanos ce dimanche 15
février à
15h en promotion d'honneur c'est le
match de la peur trappe 10e du
classement affronte Chantelou lesévg 11e
du championnat et relégable ce dimanche
au stade de Gilbert chansac trappe doit
impérativement l'emporter à domicile
pour espérer se maintenir en fin de
saison les trapistes auront besoin de
leur public pour les soutenir dans cette
course en maintien
et puis un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer
à 50 ans en ivin voisin Lebreton
organise un tournoi national de
badminton ce ce samedi 14 février une
centaine de joueurs sont attendus pour
l'événement au Centre sportif les
pyramides si vous voulez assister à la
manifestation le rendez-vous est
programmé de 13h à 19h voilà pour les
rendez-vous du weekend merci Michel à
bientôt et tout de suite l'actualité
cinéma du
weekend et place tout de suite au coup
cœur de la semaine celui d'un
professionnel du 7è Mar avec l'ubbequan
du ciné7 des 7 mars à hencour les deux
coup de cœur ciné cette semaine euh ce
deux très beaux films un qu'on a à
l'affiche depuis très longtemps qui
s'appelle Tim bookou que dont vous avez
dû entendre parler ça se passe
évidemment à tambouou et ça raconte en
fait la façon c'est malheureusement
d'actualité dont les comment dirais-je
les les habitants se retrouvent sous le
jou des islamistes qui leur donne tout
un tas d'obligations c'est très réaliste
c'est un film très triste c'est un très
très beau film avec de très belles
images notamment mais très bien joué
aussi et le deuxième c'est une promesse
que j'ai fait à AA Mayou qu'on a reçu
qui est un réalisateur qu'on a reçu
mercredi dernier c'est son film fièvre
qui est un très beau film qui l'a pour
le coup se passe en banlieu et qui R qui
raconte pardon la les relations
difficiles entre un fils euh qui n'a
jamais vécu avec son père et qui revient
vivre avec son père parce que sa mère
est emprisonnée son père vivant lui-même
avec ses propres
parents 10 an pour
rire 10 ans pour
penser 10 ans pour
aimer
je vous en dis pas plus il y a une
séance samedi à 18h30 c'est un film qui
est sorti fin 2014 et qu'il faut
absolument voir fièvre dichou au ciné 7
et team
bouou et comme toutes les semaines voici
les sorties ciné de la semaine et les
avis des spectateurs au micro d'Odine
assz coolfin du moins il était assez
fidèle au premier t après il va pas dans
le dans le trash enfin d'après ce qu'on
peut croire donc je trouvais ça assez
cool justement qu' s'écarte un petit peu
justement des détails du livre parce que
ça permet de voir un peu queles sont
justement ces 50 nuances de folie sans
forcément aller dans le trash et puis
c'est du tout public donc ça va il est
vraiment super bien enfin les acteurs
jouent très bien dedans mais très déçu
par la fin parce qu'on s'attend à autre
chose en fait c'est un très bon film
euh faut aller le voir moi je le raconte
pas parce que faut le voir c'était pas
mal c'est un peu différent du du du
livre il y a quelques scènes un peu
haosé qui ont pas été adapté mais sinon
non c'était pas mal passionnant de de
bout en bout un bon film très bon film
brillantissime je
salue cette œuvre qui est vraiment très
très bien interprété excellent un très
bon Disney ils sont vraiment très
efficaces l'animation
superbe très belle histoire en
plus allez quelques expositions pour
vous ce weekend ce samedi 14 février les
derniers jours pour en profiter
l'exposition origine de Sophie courtan
s'achève ce weekend l'artiste partage sa
perception du réel qu'elle tire de son
observation de la nature rendez-vous à
l'hôtel de ville de guyancour et du côté
de Montini le bretonnis au musée de la
ville de Saint-Quentin en Yveline une
exposition démar qu àelle ce samedi 14
février vous pouvez y découvrir
l'histoire de l'hygiène à travers
l'évolution de la salle de bain comme ce
comment se lavait-on dans les années 30
à quoi ressemble la salle de bain des
années 60 toutes les réponses dans cette
exposition jusqu'au 27
juin ce samedi 14 février à 19h une
soirée concert jazz spécial
Saint-Valentin vous est proposé une
exposition photo consacrée aux artistes
sur scène est également au menu un
apéritif dinatoire sera assuré par
l'interasos de l'université versailles-
Saint-Quentin rendez-vous au
Conservatoire Municipal des arts
plastiques et pour les amateurs de
musique classique plutôt l'orchestre
symphonique les clés de se produit ce
weekend à la batterie de Guy en cour de
quoi découvrir les œuvres du répertoire
classique à l'occasion de concerts
originaux ou insolite rendez-vous ce
samedi 14 février à 20h30 pensez à
réserver sur le site de kiosk c'est la
fin de cette édition merci de nous avoir
suivi je vous souhaite un excellent
weekend sur
TVfil